welcome everyone watching in the future
on YouTube I'm here with Tata abrahamian
along with the chasa board and we are
going to be playing against the board
but doing hand and brain
Imma Be The Hand you'll be the brain so
you'll say the name of the piece I'll
make a move and we are playing against
the AI now there's different levels of
the AI but the level is 24. so about
2400 ELO we're both around that rating
uh when it comes to feed a so hopefully
it's a good game if you want to get your
own chess support I'm leaving links in
the video description they are in stock
and they are shipping Nationwide and all
over Europe I think as well so um we're
enjoy the world actually all over the
world more information below and make a
great gift for the holidays and uh yeah
I hope you enjoy the video
okay so just to explain how the board
works when I touch the piece it will
show legal moves makes a great training
tool for newer players but we have no
assistance beyond that and feel free to
say the piece
and I'm also making the moves for the AI
Bishop
you're still happy I'm so happy
I'll make me happy
skill Theory my bread and butter
oh man
what's the theory here
I'll be very disappointed if you say the
wrong thing oh no
okay I'm very disappointed yeah I got
the feeling was it nice I mean this this
is a line This is actually a playable
line
oh my God
because there's a queen
foreign
[Music]
yeah this is uh this is actually some
Theory
I showed this to my London course
like
oh the sign
forgot about this song Oh this is crazy
oh no
oh
wow
yeah all I remember is like uh D takes
E4 and G4 H5 is uh is new for me
good luck
good luck to me good luck too
okay but both of us
[Music]
um
no
things are happening to us again
we're gonna take a deep breath
everything is under control
Maybe
yeah what is the problem
uh
stop or up a piece
that's important
Park
yep you have seven well
you're only 40.
is that what you wanted
nice
it's actually interesting
I have to think
Bishop C4 was also interesting
this looks really good for us yeah I'm
very confused I like this position
wow
and clean if I see
no matter over there
on
okay I can see the problem we're up two
phones though it's okay
you're optimistic
you can't legally Castle unfortunately
one legal Kingdom so if I say King
you'll make life really easy
um
Bishop
oh
you want to win another Pawn
the defies
okay caution
it's happening
um we are in three parts
okay
sorry not to feel okay anymore
okay
we cannot consult each other right
correct
the rules of engineering
I don't like the world
I mean you can think out loud all you
want
I don't think that's gonna help anyone
here more Deep Thoughts going through
your mind uh I only have one thought in
my brain which I cannot say
ah
that's a bit sad
I don't know if this works
problem
Queen
okay yeah I was looking in Queens
it's not that many
process illumination this is how we're
playing this game okay I mean we have
two loses a piece
it takes takes
the realism
C1 oh my God
oh wow I was thinking
Rook D1 yeah well this looks even oh man
stronger
we still have only looking
remember about Brian right now
I'm a very loud feeling we're about to
get for it
give it away all right because it's a
night going to do three actually it's 93
words for Knight F3 because Knight of
three is just mate
okay
or not yet I cannot I don't know it's
made but it's not it's very close to me
it's
not a good night
okay we're still
two Pawns
we just gotta Trail everything
let me get right on that
93 is made in two
93 yeah
so the cork is like the list of our
problems man they completely dismantle
the London I thought this was like a a
line that was good for whites
I don't know what we did wrong
maybe leaving a king in the center nah
what's wrong with the king and the sun
yes so
so much room to stretch
oh my God that's the thing I have to say
something I'm gonna say a word
today please just say something and I'll
make the most of it
coming in okay
um Bishop
okay
oh no my Bishop
wow it's not taking anything it's
playing like a bot
what a move
at least
look at box pieces
like every single piece has
a clear purpose in the position so can
we take a free vision
and a bishop oops
I honestly didn't see that
that's one way to end repeating though
it's so good twenty twenty four hundred
now
I wonder what we did wrong
I think we use my brain maybe that was
the mistake
anyway I hope you enjoyed the video I
hope you guys
learned a thing or two
how to destroy the London
if you're interested in getting a chess
up board I will leave links in the video
description uh they make a great gift
for the holidays and they are on sale I
believe too so check them out thank you
chess up for
uh existing I think you talk to the
foreign
you guys in the next video